and welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody people can't seem to get
enough of the Alec Murdock trial and
verdict and we have some updates for you
too so we now know that Murdoch has been
placed in one of the most secure areas
of Kirkland Correctional Institution in
Columbia South Carolina and that is
because there is concern that other
inmates might have it in for him due to
his notoriety Murdock once prominent
attorney turned convict is serving two
life sentences for killing his wife
Maggie and Son Paul on their country
estate in 2021. the South Carolina
Department of Corrections say that
Murdoch is being housed in a single cell
with just a bed toilet and sink he even
eats alone because he's not allowed to
mingle with the other inmates during
Meal Time Kirkland's a facility where
new inmates go to be processed and
evaluated before usually being sent on
to other prisons but Kirkland also
houses maximum security inmates the
South Carolina state senator who
represented Alec Murdock at his murder
trial dick harputlian says he's been
getting emails from people saying he did
a good job job but also emails wishing
him harm
people feel compelled to express their
opinion on things through the internet
somehow they got a hold of my I guess
it's on my website my email I really
wanted that big case you had but that's
not what they chose to send me
um most of it was very positive a lot of
it were people that were watching this
in Germany or England or the Netherlands
or I mean wacky I don't know they don't
have anything else to do in those
countries but a bunch of people here
also gave me suggestions on a daily
basis what we should do or how we
screwed up yesterday
but the folks that sent me the you are a
rotten piece of scum and I hope you die
of let me clean this up a little bit
rectal cancer
um
you know what they have a
misapprehension of the system
harputley went on to say that he's taken
an oath as an attorney to treat all
clients with fairness and integrity
regardless of the crime that they're
accused of committing Murdoch's defense
team has vowed to appeal the verdict and
we now know when another case connected
to the Murdoch family is going to go to
trial the family of Mallory Beach the 19
year old who died in a crash involving
the Murdoch family boat filed a wrongful
death lawsuit against them the trial
date is now August 14th Mark Tinsley the
attorney for Mallory Beach's mother says
that Paul Murdoch was heavily
intoxicated when he and five friends got
onto the boat in 2019 it crashed into a
bridge pylon sending Mallory into the
water boaters found her body eight days
later Tinsley says that Paul was given
preferential treatment by law
enforcement in January the beaches
actually reached a settlement with
Maggie's estate as well as Buster Alec
Murdoch's only surviving son the two
remaining defendants in the wrongful
death suit are Alec and a convenience
store where it's believed that Paul
purchased alcohol using Buster's ID
so Brian eating alone in his cell
constant monitoring a 45-day evaluation
process what does Murdoch's life look
like right now extremely isolated Jesse
now it might change after that 45-day
period but right now if he's getting the
resources that keep him safe this being
a maximum security unit at least a
maximum security unit existing within
Kirkland he might actually stay what
they do is they're looking at the
resources that they have both at this
location and all other locations where
he can be housed are what's the
population of those other prisons do
they need more people or less people
there do they have enough officers there
to take care and in the meantime he's
going to be very segregated very by
himself and it's going to feel like a
very very long life sentence and Terry
like two life sentences consecutive he's
not getting out why is it so important
to investigate the other deaths like
misspeech you know it's important
because the families have to have
closure if you think about it there is
obviously Mallory Beach but there's
Gloria Satterfield there's Steven Smith
and they're investigating all of these
cases to determine whether or not there
was any Foul Play and as it relates to
Stephen Smith you know the fact that he
was found in the middle of the road but
now it seems like he might have been
killed and placed there Gloria
Satterfield was it an accident did she
actually fall down the stairs and
Mallory Beach as well so we'll see what
happens but it's important for these
families to have some kind of closure
absolutely every victim matters and
sticking in that area of the country to
South Carolina officers are being
commended for their actions after they
pulled over a woman for driving
erratically she had originally been
reported as a drunk driver but the
officers quickly realized there might be
something else going on here
man we're gonna have you go with the
ambulance okay and the reason for that
is you're not driving away we can't let
you drive away okay and um you like
you've been pulled over three times
today now okay I think you I think
something medical is going on with you
and you really need to go to the
hospital and get checked out you might
be you might be suffering from you might
be suffering from maybe an aneurysm
right now or like something going on in
your head so that woman Tamara Palmer
was transported to the hospital in
December she contacted the police
department last month to give them an
update it turns out she had a brain
tumor she immediately underwent an
eight-hour surgery and says that she's
doing well Palmer credits those two
officers with saving her life
prosecutors in Virginia say they won't
bring charges against a six-year-old boy
who shot his teacher during class in
January Commonwealth Attorney Howard
Gwynn spoke to NBC news saying that a
first grader run trial would be
problematic because someone that young
doesn't really understand the justice
system and wouldn't be considered
competent however prosecutors could
criminally charge him under Virginia law
and several parents with children in the
school just the school district believe
that not doing so sets a really bad
example but local law enforcement has
shifted their focus towards adults
associated with the case including the
boyzone parents the Newport News police
chief said that their complicated
investigation included coordinating
interviews with first graders and those
could only happen alongside a child
psychologist and with the permission of
the parents if the case were to go to
trial those interviews could potentially
be used as testimony we spoke with
forensic psychologist Dr John De la
Torre to give us an idea of how that
might work
questioning of a juvenile when it comes
to understanding their their competency
is a much more delicate and nuanced uh
interview when you're with an adult you
can kind of be a little bit more
aggressive you can be a little bit more
forceful you can actually do a whole lot
more sort of guiding along with
remediation during that entire interview
process
when it comes to interviewing a juvenile
deal where you're you're having to do a
lot of hand holding you're you're
certainly looking at where is this
individual developmentally both
cognitively and maturity level it's
certainly a difficult thing
given how young these children are that
they might not have seen any yellow or
red flags that older children read
teenagers at you know college students
and other workplace individuals that had
the children been older that they might
have seen sort of issues that were going
on at play and actually been able to
provide an intervention looking at how
young these children are in this
classroom can be very difficult because
they may not actually have an awareness
of what's going on around them the way
that others older would have been able
to to participate Brian how does a
district attorney's office interview a
class of six-year-olds and to help come
to the conclusion that their classmate
won't be charged Jesse the simple answer
very very carefully these are probably
going to be individual interviews with a
parent and child psychologist there and
what you've got to do first is you've
got to get a baseline does this child
understand the difference between right
and wrong telling the truth or telling a
fib let's say right and when you get
that Baseline then you can start putting
together what they did or didn't see
understanding that their ability to
recollect information is not the same as
you or I as adults and so what you're
really looking at is kind of getting
this puzzle piece that may not really
fit the overall picture that you're
trying to seek but you still got to take
that puzzle piece put it into the puzzle
overall and see where it matches and how
you can create a narrative to further
your goal as a district attorney so
Terry the six-year-old's not going to be
criminally charged but what about the
parents what about the school
administrators could they be criminally
charged well the parents could have
misdemeanor criminal charges against
them because they did not secure that
gun that the 60 year old got a hold of
there's a statute in Virginia that would
make them responsible but I think that
this School administration probably will
be able to avoid any sort of criminal
charges there is a civil case pending
against the school administrators and we
heard the attorney say that they were
ignoring multiple warnings that day with
the other teachers who were actually
telling the administration that the
child had a gun and it was totally
ignored so I do think in the Civil Trial
they should be responsible for that
shooting and pay to the victims of that
shooting and thankfully she's doing well
yeah thankfully she survived this
because this could have been so much
worse